now in 2001
uh then secretary of defense donald
rumsfeld published
in the wall street journal a list of
rules reflections and quotations
under the title rumsfeld's rules uh it's
a brilliant piece
and i recommend it to you it's easily
found online
but one of those rules under the topic
keep your bearings
in the white house read like this
when asked for your views by the press
or others remember that what they really
want to know
is the president's views so in that
spirit
let me surrender the podium immediately
to my boss
who will make some remarks and introduce
and have a discussion then with our main
speaker
please welcome the 12th president of
hillsdale college
now in his 11th year in that position dr
larry yarn
good evening thank you all for being
here
we've survived the afternoon rains
you know up in hillsdale michigan it
gets really cold
and we didn't get a spring this year and
we attribute that to the weather
prognostications of
albert gore
and i see he's been very helpful to your
weather down here too
uh the trustees here tonight are uh they
didn't get their names called out so i'm
going to call them out because i want to
ask
one of them and his daughter to stand up
there are gunner clar
and mark johnson and jack stahlsby along
with bill broadbeck
and uh gunnar clara's married to a
searle
and our speaker tonight ran gd searle
for some years and
magnificently ran it and so we have a
family gathering here tonight from the
hillsdale college board
and one of the products of the searle
family
is granddaughter abigail who's just
married a new guy
and he doesn't seem worthy to me
although dad seems to like him
and so i'd like the clars to stand up
please
gunner's married to sally and she's real
pretty as you can divine from looking at
abigail
and the son-in-law you stand up too
see that didn't look quite right does it
nice to have you here young man
torturing the young that's what i do for
a living
and jack stallsby over there has been
driving me absolutely crazy about
elizabeth ames jones who stood up
politicians are getting a lot better
looking aren't they
and that's not why jack likes her though
she's apparently a woman a very good
principal
and you should stand up again you get
three times then
as you can tell so far i'm i'm feeling
really gloomy
and there's a lot to be gloomy about
you know tomorrow in new york in a
congressional election that
conservative candidates have been
winning lately it looks like uh
a liberal person is going to win the
seat by running against the paul ryan
proposals for entitlement
reform and paul ryan himself i can tell
you thinks
that if we don't get some kind of
entitlement reform in the next three or
four years we're going to be
submerged under our debt that's a very
bad sign
europe is in a mess of insolvency and
stagnation
the arab spring tends toward winter
hezbollah and hamas and the muslim
brotherhood prosper
the economy is slowing and the stock
market is falling
scott walker of wisconsin and rick scott
of florida and nikki haley of south
carolina and chris christie of new
jersey
i've met three of them lately and
they're just awesome
but they're all too young to run for
president right now they think and
probably are
and mitch daniels has just said he's not
going to do it
how will we ever get out of this mess
but two things make me hopeful so i'm in
fact i'm not gloomy
i did study winston churchill for some
years and
believe that's wrong to ever be that way
one of them is what i see about me when
i go to work
ryan walsh of recent hillsdale college
graduation
has just been made the editor of the law
review at the university of chicago law
school
and he likes to say that his colleagues
who are on the law review at
harvard and yale and there are several
of them are weenies because
in those places they don't give real
grades
and at chicago they grade on the curve
and ryan is at the top
applications to our college have gone up
two and a half times in a decade
applications to liberal arts colleges in
general are falling
there are 50 charter schools in
texas whose chief
today at lunch asked me if we would be
prepared to supply them headmasters and
curricula
for all 50 of them
and uh in the back of the room are
several people who are going to end up
doing that job i can tell you from the
reception
so one reason is there's hope
because there are people around who want
to fight and that's what makes a
difference
nothing else does come to find out
if you love good things and you can see
them in your eyes and you can serve them
with your heart
that is the strongest single force on
earth and it doesn't matter
about these other things however
numerous or powerful they are
or however overwhelming they seem to be
and the second reason i'm not gloomy is
because for the last three or four days
i've been studying the career of the
person that's going to speak to us
tonight
i've had the privilege of knowing him
for a long time
he's the 13th and the 21st united states
secretaries of defense secretary of
defense
and as you know because you've all
counted them up in article 1 section 8
of the constitution there are
17 clauses and 9 of them concerned
defense
and since henry knox
the secretary of defense has always been
one of the most important officers
of the in the american government and
our speaker tonight
is one of the most illustrious
illustrious of them all
now it wouldn't surprise you that he's
an aggressive man he grew up in illinois
and he's a wrestler
the first time i met him he gave me a
contribution
he was very nice but of course he just
beat the tar out of me the whole time we
were talking
and he fastened onto the fact that i'm
from arkansas
and and so he began to belabor me with
that fact what a miserable place that
was to be from
see he's shaking his head now but this
is the god's truth and he said
and he said you know arkansas illinois
that's where he's from had produced
abraham lincoln
and arkansas had produced you know
and you know he's he's a great man and i
am not
and so i was i was very honored to be
there and it was not it didn't seem like
for a while a very equal
contest until finally made me mad
and i pointed out that it is true that
abraham lincoln was so incomparably a
better president than
bill clinton that it's almost like it's
not the same job when he's doing it
but on the other hand bill clinton
running for president
had never carried arkansas
[Applause]
as you can see i was like the fellow on
the edge of the cliff holding on by his
fingernails
and there was this big bully up there
and he was standing on them
he was a naval aviator he was an eagle
scout of course
he was a naval aviator he was a
congressman
four terms in a row he was a good
congressman
that is to say if it was a question
of voting for the strength of our
country
located in its military but behind that
and more profoundly in the freedom
and the energy and the latitude to act
of the american people
he was the supporter and the nourisher
of the tap root of america
somehow he figured out how to do that
he was called away by nixon to work in
the nixon administration and nixon
referred to him as a really tough guy
he surely is that
he was the transition chairman for
gerald ford into the white house
and then he became the chief of staff
and that's when he began to run to write
those famous rumsfeld rules which you
must look up on the internet
he told me tonight maybe he'll write a
book about that and i can tell you his
current book which he was signing
tonight
if you haven't read it you should read
it because it has two things about it
that are remarkable and i speak to
somebody who uh
helped to write the biography of winston
churchill the big one
he wants to demonstrate things with
documentary evidence taken from the time
and there's he tells me a website i
haven't been there
where there are hundreds thousands of
documents published that you can go look
up the truth
in other words he wishes to demonstrate
a thing and you know the wish to
prove a thing is an act of charity
that's what you do for people you
respect
think of the fact that ronald reagan's
speeches like winston churchill speeches
were beautiful
explanations he took the trouble to make
it clear to tell you why it was good
to explain to you to work to make it in
terms comprehensible to you
and then father follow the patterns of
speech
of the current occupier of that position
i swore i wouldn't mention his name so i
won't
our speaker has been the the director of
the central intelligence agency
and the president's personal
representation representative to the
middle east
he shook the hand of saddam hussein
little did he know that saddam was
shaking the hand of the man who would
kill him
like a lot of people who've become
important in politics
secretary rumsfeld has done well for
himself economically
unlike almost all of them he actually
did that in a private
capacity in competition with other
people
not writing a book telling dirty stories
about his comrades
there are no dirty stories in this book
although the truth will
out if you will read carefully and you
will see
the record of what's happened he'll talk
about that some tonight i imagine
and he didn't do it by lobbying the
government for stuff
he ran it he did it by running two big
companies in exactly the same spirit
as he ran various important departments
in the united states government
i thought him for a long time now he's
been one of my favorite people for a
long time even though he was mean to me
because uh our the story of our nation
if you just read it
is written in the history of people who
are independent citizens
who came from nowhere the way any
american does
the whole country does who went into
public service
who made their living independent of
that who served for nothing in most of
the jobs they held he's done that over
and over
and who on the other hand didn't
think that when they went into politics
it was a reward for something they had
achieved
it was an honor to be there and serve
an honor that can only be vindicated
by the service that is honest and
obedient
rumsfeld's rules are about the people
that you must obey
above all the people of the united
states of america
and secondarily the people that they
have elected
churchill said once no longer civil
no longer servants that is the plague
of the age our speaker tonight is an
exception to it
welcome donald rumsfeld
thank you sir
now i've got the mic
goodness gracious where do you find
people like that
first of all i'm delighted to be here
i'm a
fan of hillsdale i don't want him to
know it but i'm a fan of
larry yarn i
have the privilege of having a hillsdale
graduate work in my office and she's
terrific
i thought what i would do
is talk for about three or four minutes
and then
sit down and respond to the questions
that you ask and
we'll see if i answer any of his but
but i did spend four years
working on the book known and unknown
i enjoyed it it was a long gestation
period
the larry mentioned that on
www.rumsfeld.com
i've got over 3 000 documents that the
book is rooted in
there is an enhanced ebook
that someone can actually read a
paragraph in the book
go to the endnote and then pull up the
entire document
i don't know that that's been done
before
you notice he was working off his ipad
i want the record to show i didn't bring
mine
the the
the the book is something that i hope
people will read partly because
the proceeds my proceeds not the
publishers but my proceeds are going to
the troops and their families and to the
children of those who've fallen
military charities
i i i also hope people read it
and i think you know if you want to get
your christmas card list and buy a lot
of them and send them all out
it's it's a good cause but i hope people
will read it who are interested in
government seriously interested
because i think they'll find in there
how things are really decided how things
work in government
the fact that policy makers at that
level all the easy decisions get made
down below but they're faced with
incomplete information imperfect
information sometimes inaccurate
information
and and i've tried to show that those
issues have two sides that there are
different approaches that one can take
that there are pros and cons for those
kinds of issues and
and i hope that from that people will
feel a the importance of public service
that uh in fact there's a um a speech in
there on public service that i
in the website that i hope people will
go to
and uh and and particularly young people
i
i think that it can get pretty
discouraging when people read the press
and watch television
public service can and and i'm a great
believer in the private sector believe
me that's where the jobs come from
that's where the products come from
that's where the opportunities come from
that's the thing that distinguishes this
wonderful country
but i also think that people who have a
background in business and
and the private sector can bring a lot
to government
uh because that balance that perspective
is is critically important so with that
i'll
say that i will go and put my whatever
it's called back on and we'll start
thank you
[Applause]
just you gonna do this without your ipad
no i have it right here
okay and the reason is i was worried and
the reason is i have your book on it
and i'm i was about to say the phrases
are not memorable enough
that i don't need to consult them but
that's not even true
you know you see what he's like
it's terrible no
he says so i'm not going to ask this
question first this this concerns
something i'll save till last and uh
secretary thank you again for being here
thank you sir
honor to us all um
is it wise to support the removal of
assad of syria
or should we keep doing what we're doing
i don't know that anyone's trying to
remove him
uh first in fact there have been a
series of administrations that have
hoped that he would behave and that that
regime would behave
indeed recently uh the secretary of
state
mrs clinton announced that he was a
reformer
which i hadn't noticed
we've had a series of government
officials traipse into
into damascus to meet with um the assad
family i
have met with his father i have not met
this one
is that echoing funny is that better
good um and if
if you look at that part of the world
what's really important it seems to me
is iran
and syria they're linked at the hips
iran's working on nuclear weapons and
they their closest
linkage and ally in syria are the ones
that
are supporting terrorist organizations
and causing
difficulties in lebanon and elsewhere in
the world
certainly they're causing difficulties
in afghanistan and iraq
the world would be a considerably better
place without the assad family
what would replace him is the question
and one can't know that it's it's not
knowable
it is a known unknown
[Applause]
the uh the other important parts of that
world i would say are egypt with 60
million people
and uh and saudi arabia and the gulf
where
the anchors they're considerably more
important than libya or
yemen or tunisia or some of the other
countries
in your book you uh followed up on that
you call for uh
your suggestion is that we might have
followed somewhat more limited
objectives in iraq than the ones we have
followed
and i wonder if you could comment on
that and how that might apply to a place
like syria
i've never believed that it's possible
for
our country or possibly it's still
actively funny isn't it
higher is better
how's that
we'll try it um bad
who's in charge of this
oh you got it on wrong here
my father would say if the car wasn't
working there's a nut loose behind the
steering wheel
here
did he say what i thought he said
let's have another question
so did you hear that question i heard it
that was a good question
you liked that one yeah let me ask you
in some other way
can we be players in a world with china
oh my goodness yes who would ask that
i don't know would you hold up your hand
china you know i read all this stuff
about china and china is a big country
although it looks like india may end up
being larger in size
china has a good growth rate
and they're investing in their military
capabilities
but they've got problems they've got
difficulties with some of their
neighbors
and vietnam and india and even
occasionally with
russia they had this one baby
policy which led to a not very many
female babies and a lot of male babies
and that's a
problem that they're going to face a
serious problem if they're going to face
they've got
a lot of different ethnic groups in the
in the country
some of them are not comfortable with
the central government
they have a disparity a very wealthy
coast and a not so wealthy
rest of the country they still have
large
government entities that have to
eventually are terribly inefficient
are going to have to be uh dropped out
and they they run the risk of
turmoil and and protests and the like
um they have this basic problem of
of a increasingly free
economic system which is benefiting them
but a
less free and unfree political system
and one has to believe that that is not
going to be perfectly compatible over
time
so i i think that the you know ringing
our hands and worrying about china
is probably not something we need to do
we we need to behave ourselves
and manage our relationship with them
and and uh
and recognize that they play a long game
they they don't play checkers or even
chess they play multi-dimensional chess
and um they're busy around the world
they're they're
clearly developing a much stronger
military
but they're also out dispensing money in
different parts of the world giving a
soccer stadium to this country and a
presidential palace to that country and
assisting with a yacht for some poke
somewhere else trying to
to buy friendship and they do a pretty
good job of it and and uh
but they're they're they're an
uncomfortable neighbor for all their
neighbors
and uh the fact that india is a freer
system
and a growing system and will be playing
a bigger part in the world i think is
probably uh
not a bad balance uh
so i i think we ought to keep our eye on
what they're doing and and
and try to manage our i can't imagine
that they think it's in their interest
for example to go after taiwan
uh they've been deploying all kinds of
ballistic missiles and
aimed at taiwan and threatening but the
economic
back and forth between taiwan and the
mainland today is extensive
and uh i i can't believe they they're
gonna i mean they clearly wanted to
reunify greater china and they brought
macau in and they brought hong kong in
and they love to have taiwan come in but
i i think
the idea of their doing it militarily in
in the near term is
is highly unlikely are there things we
should be doing militarily
to match them that we're not doing
well you know what our country seems to
do is at the end of world war ii we
we take a sigh of relief and cut the
defense budget and then after korean war
we
sigh of relief and cut the defense
budget and after vietnam we
cut the defense budget and you end up
doing a bathtub
and drawing down our intelligence
capabilities drawing down our military
capabilities and
we did it after the end of the cold war
and the the decade of the 90s another
bathtub and it was harmful and when
president george
w bush came in the intelligence
capabilities had been
thinned out and our military
capabilities had declined
uh and and uh if we do it again
simply because the the problems we've
got with debt are crushing
we have to do something about it but
people who are running around saying you
can balance the federal budget off the
defense department are just wrong
the entitlements is where it is and
when i went to washington in 1957 and
served in the 60s the defense budget was
about 10 percent of the gross domestic
product of our country during the
eisenhower kennedy and johnson period
today i think it's 3.8 percent something
like that
so it's it's not as though the defense
budget is what's causing the trillions
of dollars
of debt and deficits it is it is
unquestionably in the entitlement area
and there is no
other way to tackle it and we must
tackle it
here's a question about russia do you
do you think they're on a good track or
are they going to be a problem for us or
well they've got a lot of nuclear
weapons uh but the country is
in trouble they've got problems with
alcoholism they've got problems with
tuberculosis they've got a large prison
population they have a military
where a lot of the conscripts in the
enlisted ranks don't want to be there
they have an outflow of technical
competence and
well-trained scientific people um
yeah i think it's the first
industrialized country in the world that
has actually had a declining
life expectancy for males
their gdp is probably the size of
portugal
if you take out their energy component
and
it is not a bright prospect for russia
it's not well-run
uh they're kind of reverting to more of
an authoritarian system less of a
democratic system
and uh and their behavior is uh
i mean if you're if you're a businessman
and this room's filled with them and
you're sitting in dallas or chicago or
somewhere else you want to know where to
put a marketing arrangement or where you
want to put a scientific
development research and development
plan or you want to put a
manufacturing plant and you look around
the world i mean you look for certain
things you look for rule of law you look
for
educational systems and you look for an
environment that's hospitable to
enterprise
and this the russia does not offer
an environment that's hospitable to
enterprise so which suggests to me
that people all across the globe will be
except in the energy area people are
going to be making decisions to go
somewhere other
than russia and and that doesn't bode
well for them
and of course who do they hang around
with they walk around with with uh
cuba and venezuela and and syria
and iran um some of the same allies
we've got
who's in charge here
uh given the economic troubles you
mentioned in the debt
somebody wonders is it time to bring our
troops home and get out of all these
countries we're in spread around the
world
well i think i think we do have to watch
where we position our forces
when president bush came in he asked me
to work on re-balancing our forces they
were
kind of left over from the cold war and
and they were in some places uh where
the countries
were not terribly hospitable they were
in some places where they
for us to move them to do something in
our national interest required that we
go to the government and then they go to
their parliaments
and and we don't need that we don't need
one military for the united states and
one for germany and one for japan and
one for korea
so we started moving them around in ways
that they're much better positioned
today
but i i do think that that uh
we have limits and and we don't need to
be
in a lot of places uh
i'll give you one little example of of
how hard
change is we were spending 236 million
dollars
to have air force capabilities in
iceland when i arrived in 2001
236 million dollars a year
and the planes had been put there to
track
soviet bombers
the soviet union had been gone for a
decade
we seem not to realize that
it took me four and a half years as i
recall
to get that moved out of there at a cost
of 236
million dollars a year nobody wanted to
do it
they wanted to leave everything the way
it was
that's just one example of of the
difficulty of
contending with the iron triangle in
washington dc
the the permanent bureaucracy in the
pentagon
the congress and the contracting
community and
in this case the state department that
didn't want to rock the boat
with the icelanders and to some extent
with some of our nato allies
that didn't want iceland to be upset
because
those aircraft were serving a very
important purpose for iceland
they were doing search and rescue for
the iceland fishing fleet
at 236 million dollars a year now that's
just one example
of the things we were doing and in some
instances still are doing
that we ought not to be doing that we
don't need to be doing and that we
shouldn't be doing given the
the the debt i mean we're b i was with
an
asian statesman not too long ago and he
said to me he never thought he'd live to
see adults in the white house in the
united states of america
modeling america on europe
and and uh with the debt we have we
can't be doing those things that we
don't need to do
and any and you know i don't mean to
suggest you can't cut the defense budget
the congress every year jams about 10
billion
down the pentagon's throat that they
don't want that has nothing to do with
defense
at all totally unrelated to the defense
department
before i'm remembering before the war
started when you were secondary defense
the second time there was some conflict
there were
articles in the paper about how you were
trying to cut precious things and there
was resistance
how would you go about reform in the
military today what changes would you
make to it
well um i mean the
one of the big things that happened was
i cut the crusader artillery piece
isn't that a wonderful name
in the environment we're in uh this
thing
was so big it took you kind of like it
yeah it took two
large cargo aircraft to move the thing
and a long period to assemble it and
here we are dealing largely with
unconventional threats
and asymmetrical threats and
i just made a judgment that we'd be much
better off with high
very good precision artillery capability
and
and to cancel that i cancel it and you'd
think the roof would fall in it i mean
it was just
there's so much momentum behind a major
weapon system
uh in in in washington once it gets
going the jobs the contractors the
congressmen who are committed to it
the people in the building who who had
worked on it for you know eight ten
twelve years and no one wants to stop
anything like that
and and uh here we are what uh ten years
later and
nobody thinks we should have left it
today i mean it just
it was wrong and that is hard to do
um you know but if you're going to get
traction
i suppose you first have to have
friction and and
see it's that means that it's not just
uh
listening to the experts because they
want the weapon
and it's not just overriding them
it takes how do you do that how do you
figure that out so you do the right
thing for the public
well you you uh you talk to all the
people who have knowledge that you don't
have
and and then you kind of calculate
how how much pain for the gain
because you can only do so many of those
things back back in 1975
the at about seven o'clock at night and
i talked about this in the book
uh in came the army and the acquisition
people
from the osd and the issue was the main
battle tank for the united states of
america
and the army decided they wanted to
recommend 105 howitzer
and a diesel tank which is what we'd
always had
and the acquisition people in osd
decided they wanted a 120 millimeter
howitzer because it was
more compatible with our nato allies and
they wanted a turbine
engine instead of a diesel engine and it
was seven o'clock at night
and the everyone expected me to agree
with them and they were totally in
so i said look i'm not gonna do it i'm
gonna wait six six seven eight weeks
which we did and i poured my head into
it and concluded that the army was wrong
and that we should go for the 120
howitzer and the turbine
engine we did and it performed
and of course the congress went nuts the
contracting community went nuts there
were hearings
it was sacrilegious to not agree with
the army
how could you do that and the retired
community was up in arms
and and in the gulf war the tanks
performed
brilliantly and and the armored people
very really like the abrams tank today
now the pain from that was enormous
you know the headline in the army times
was why does rumsfeld hate the army
that kind of thing but but i guess
that's just the way it is uh somebody
has to decide and
and uh you can't agree with everybody
and if you make those decisions um
there'll be people who won't like it and
if you're not willing to do that you you
shouldn't be in government
i once counted up the years incidentally
in which uh winston churchill was in
government in in
in ministry in which he was fighting for
a smaller
and the years in which he was fighting
for a larger
defense estimates they call it in
england and the years where he was
fighting for a smaller one out number of
the years where he was fighting for a
larger one
he met something yeah he was pugnacious
[Laughter]
too
that was a compliment
what do you think of the tea parties and
is a restoration of constitutional
government in america a real possibility
i think the tea party is a good thing it
shows that there's energy out there in
the country
people are interested and you know
throughout our history
if if things get out of whack
at some point good people get out of
their chairs and spend more time and
they push the pendulum back where it
belongs
and i i kind of take the tea party as
doing that today that
that things have tipped too far
and uh and the concern is is greater so
people who may not have been involved
previously decided they want to get
involved
and i personally think that's a good
thing we we benefit
in our country having that kind of
recalibration which occurs when
a larger number of our population decide
they're going to
uh do what a lot of folks in this room
do even
even before where they say they want to
help guide and direct the course of the
country because they think the
course of the country isn't where it
ought to be going
anybody here remember the tea party
oh this is good what has been your best
moment in politics
and your worst
well this is going to sound ridiculous
but but you didn't even mention
that i was in charge of the wage price
controls that richard nixon
[Applause]
imposed on our country and and
and this is you think it's the worst it
happens to be the best
and i'll explain why it was in
in government it's rarely comes out
exactly the way you want it
there's too many people pulling and
tugging but in this instance
it did here's what happened george
schultz came to me and said
president and i want you to run the wage
price controls i said that's nice george
but i don't believe in him and he said i
know don
that's why we want you to do it
so i started doing it and what i did was
the first thing i said was oh my
goodness it's an election period
and we've got the power over wages and
prices in the united states now is that
a formula for corruption
and people started coming to me and say
oh we can we can remake america in our
image here we can control wages and
prices
and fix the health care system or we can
control wages and prices and damage the
unions
or we can control wages and prices and
help the unions
and i said we're not going to do
anything other than
deal with inflation that's why the
legislation was passed
it doesn't matter who comes in and wants
what we're not going to do anything
other than that number one number two
every time there's a regulation we're
going to stick it on the side of the
wall
and and see the damage we're doing as it
grows up the side of the wall
third if there's even a smell of
corruption
we're going to send it to the department
of justice instantaneously
and fourth we're not going to have a
single employee who's permanent
everyone here is going to be detailed
from another department
so you can get rid of them in one second
and nobody
you don't end up with a whole bunch of
people who want to perpetuate themselves
in that job
we did that then we said we're going to
start letting everyone go
not everyone we we we tiered them we had
the big companies the medium size and
the small
we let all the small out don't worry go
your
way the middle we asked just
report periodically and the big ones
that have all the lobbyists and all the
lawyers they were the ones that we dealt
with
at one point milton friedman called me
up and he said don you are doing
a terrible job i said
milton we are doing a spectacular job
we are letting everyone out from under
this so that no pressure will build and
and
he said you are doing a terrible job
because you are doing such a good job
people are going to think that wage
price controls work
and and they're going to get the wrong
lesson from all of this
i i told him not to worry we're going to
get rid of these things
and we did
now everyone here knows that milton
friedman was a nobel prize winning
economist a monetarist
you know i knew him myself very well
really great guy he spoke for the
college about three months before he
died and you had a big relationship with
him you knew him for a long time
tell about him and about what you
learned from him oh he was he was just
wonderful as a human being he had this
great energy
and love of life and sparkle
he came to me i met him first in the
early 1960s when i was in congress and i
was at a
conference at the university of chicago
center for continuing education
and the subject was the draft and um
he got me interested in in moving from a
compulsory
military draft system to an
all-volunteer army
and i ended up testifying in the
congress
uh for an all-volunteer army and of
course
there was a funny thing going on the
military
liked the compulsion because it was the
only thing in our society where we
forced people to do something
it was the only single vocation or
activity of government
where we required that people do it
the academic community liked it because
they got an exemption
so teachers didn't have to do it
students didn't have to do it anyone who
was married didn't have to do it
women didn't have to do it conscientious
objectors didn't have to do it
and then we turned around to the handful
that we did make do it
under the the draft system and told them
we're going to pay you 60 50 60 70
of the civilian manpower market not only
are you not going to be able to do what
you want
and these other people can uh but we're
going to pay
much less i remember going to a pta
meeting with one of my daughters in
the it was a history class and they
showed the reading list i looked up
there every book had been written in the
last 15 minutes
and i went up the guy and i said is this
history or current events he said it's
history
i said how'd you happen to become a
history teacher he said i didn't want to
go in the draft
so so milton freeman talked me into it
and sure enough richard nixon thanks to
him
he pushed it through and and uh and
the system we have today is working
brilliantly
we've got a terrific members and men and
women in the armed forces of the united
states they do a great job they're there
because they want to be there
and they all raised their hands and said
send me and and we're so fortunate that
that they're there doing what they do
and and and milton friedman was
a big pusher for that
you notice i didn't answer the last part
of the question
yeah i don't intend to
i met you before i surmised that
i could ask again and we'd just get the
same point again
what in your what made you interested in
public life why did you go into public
service
well my dad was a old man he was
38 or 9 when world war ii broke out
and he had a wife and kids and he
volunteered to go in the
navy and they didn't want him he was
you know he didn't fit what they were
looking for and uh
and then we started losing battle after
battle in the pacific and pretty soon
they
took him and uh he was out in the
pacific on a carrier and and
you know when you're young i was
well that was it was nine years old in
1941
and um it's you're impressed
by that and i was around military bases
and lived in coronado when he was out in
the carrier
and i got interested in the war i was
interested in in the military i was
interested in public service i was
interested in
president roosevelt because he was the
president of the united states and
and was the commander-in-chief and i
began reading and thinking about it i
went to college and
natalie stevenson spoke at my senior
banquet in college
and gave this his speech is on my
website also
and it was a wonderful speech about
public service it was it was a
really inspirational he was a fine
speaker and probably would not have been
a very good president he lost
eisenhower twice as you all know but uh
but the speech is a good one and then i
went in the navy
and uh i i started
in government at uh right out of college
as a pilot
and flight instructor and uh
i read history read biography which i
guess
is history without theory isn't that
right something like that
isn't that what disraeli said i think
you should know
see i i could lie to him and agree with
him
but with this guy you don't know if he's
not going to turn on after you do that
so the sorry truth is i'm going to obey
one of rumsfeld's rules which is
if if you don't know say that and if you
do it the right amount it will be often
i don't know the other one is if in
doubt don't
if still in doubt do the right thing
what's right
that's right that was my dad
i'm going to read you the quote from
adlai stevenson the book ends with it by
the way
you should read this book it's it's a
do you ever read books by politicians
well the point is if they're any good
they didn't write them
and this one's good and i happen to know
because the the young woman in question
is elisa quiatek
graduated second or third in her class
three four years ago really bright
really great parents people from dayton
ohio and uh
apart from my own perceptions of the
secretary
one of my girls has been working for him
for some years
she thinks he hung the moon she was the
fact checker
here's how the book ends our still young
country has withstood tragedies and
trauma of unimagined scope
mrs rumsfeld writing and yet it has
continued to thrive
thanks to proud and resilient citizens
and leaders from both
political parties who have done their
best to guide the nation
quote if those young americans who have
the advantage of education
perspective and self-discipline do not
participate to the fullest extent of
their ability
america will stumble and if america
stumbles the world
falls for the power for good or evil of
this american political organization is
virtually beyond measure
the decisions which it makes the uses to
which it devotes its immense resources
the leadership which it provides on
moral as well as material questions
all appear likely to determine the fate
of the modern world
then rumsfeld writes these words remain
as true and profound today
is when i first heard them at my senior
class banquet in 1954 at princeton
it's it's a speech worth looking at on
the website the stevenson
speech if people are interested in
public service or
you know young people who might be
uh you've been beat up a little bit in
interviews about your book
people somebody here notices
what's that about why why why is there's
unanimous against you from those who
have it well
there's a narrative out there and uh it
i'm guessing it was basically written by
journalists who weren't there
weren't involved in the decisions it was
written by
authors who talked to people in many
cases that were two or three levels down
and it's got to be jarring to have a
book come out
that is counter to the narrative and
in some instances it is and and that's
awkward for people who are
are invested in the narrative and uh
and their supporters which is why i
decided to take four years
and and and and document the book with
i don't know 1300 endnotes and 3 000
some odd documents on the website
because i
i knew there would be people who would
find it inconsistent with the narrative
and and that's fine
mine's right
so uh this uh something about something
else about the book and about you remind
me of churchill
um the book is full of cautions
of uh trying to do too much with the
military
of going too far of expecting too much
from settlements after wars are won
of on and on and on every
every well i confess i already told him
i always tell him the truth because he's
quick and he'll make fun of you
but uh i've read about 40 of the book
and the last chapter
and uh and i hate skimmers yeah yeah
and he's an expert all of a sudden
let's put it this way this is a very
fine book
if i read aristotle's nickel mckee in
ethics i read it more carefully
all right all right all right all right
if if uh
but that's a first of all that's a
surprising thing and by the way
read books by winston churchill this
they're good in the same way this book
is
they're full of the same thing over and
over again the guy
thinks that war is a devastating thing
and you
better be careful about it and if you
fight it
you better have a lot of respect for it
now that's
you on the one hand and you on the other
hand
is the guy in september october and
november
2001 and later when we iraq stuff starts
and you perfect the use in public speech
of the word
kill because there's a bunch of people
we're about to go get
and you want them to be afraid and so
it's like the career of churchill isn't
it he's the guy who stood up and said
what is our policy it is to wage war
the wage war with all the strength
that's in us
all the might that god can give us right
i wrote a paper in i think march
of 2001 well before september 11th
and it's also on the website and it's
called guidelines
for the use of military power or
military force
where i i sat down for the president
uh and members of the national security
council some thoughts
uh about being careful about the use of
of military power and recognizing that
there are certain things
we can't do and understanding our limits
uh and uh i reread it not too long ago
and it it still feels right
i did another memo that's on there that
someone called the parade of horribles
uh and and it was before
before we went into iraq months many
months before
probably four five six and i sat down
and and listed all the things that could
go wrong
and all the things i could think of that
would go wrong and
uh brought them up in a national
security council meeting and then went
back to the office
and circulated it to three or four
people and asked them to
add things and and calibrate it and
polish it and then we send it around to
the members of the national security
council
uh what i should have done is
also written something all the things
that could go wrong
if we didn't go after saddam hussein and
i didn't do that
although at the bottom of the memo i
said just that
that another memo could be written on
that subject and it was a it was an
effort to try to remind all of us of the
terrible
things that could go wrong and
one of them was there might not be
stockpiles of weapons of mass
destruction and the administration's
credibility would be damaged
another was that it could go on six or
eight or ten years
and uh i didn't believe those things i
didn't think they would happen but
but you you sit down and you think what
could go wrong
um one of the things that went right was
when
gaddafi saw saddam hussein being pulled
out of that spider hole
he decided he didn't want to continue
with his nuclear program
and he called in the west and they came
in and dismantled it
and uh we're the world's a better place
uh a
with saddam hussein gone and b that
qaddafi doesn't have a nuclear
and well-advanced nuclear program
you describe in the in the book uh some
change of goal about the iraq war that
you describe what's the limited thing
you're after
and and and then that the the goal
became democratization
do you could you elaborate on that a
little bit and also
explain do you think it would have gone
on this long or been this difficult if
we'd stuck to the more limited goal
well you never know you like to think
you know
but even hindsight's not 20 20.
i look at it and for some reason
the word democracy started being used
with respect to iraq
and uh for some reason i was
uncomfortable with it
i kept wanting to use the word freedom
and a freer political system and a free
or economic system
the word democracy left me with the
impression that we had in mind a
template
and it was our template it was our
democracy as we exist today
and i just don't believe that i mean
think of our country
we had slaves into the 1800s women
didn't vote into the 1900s
uh we fought a god-awful civil war some
what six or seven hundred thousand
americans
lives lost is so what we are today is
not what we were
and it's not what we will be in another
50 years i
suspect will be something different and
each of those countries have different
history different culture
different experiences different
neighbors
and they're going to evolve in a way
that fits them
i mean afghanistan's a tribal country
we're not so the i the use of the word
democracy worried me
not because i'm against democracy
but because i was afraid that it would
mean to people that we were
going to impose that template on other
countries
and i much preferred the word freedom
and uh freer political systems
and the other thing is
i worry about being too judgmental about
other countries
you know you can if this is the spectrum
and that's bad by our standards
unlike us and this is good the most like
us
and a country's over here in the bad
half
how do you deal with them or are
countries here
in the good half somewhere how do you
deal with them
my attitude is which way are they moving
if someone's over here
and he's going they're going in the
right direction they're kind of doing
things that are going to be best for
their people
they're going to have a freer political
system a freer economic system
less likely to invade their neighbors
more likely to create opportunities for
their people
that i think you encourage someone's
over here
better than this but they're going the
wrong way
then i think the task is to kind of
encourage them but i don't think we
should expect everyone to be just like
we are
because it's a big world and we're going
to have to deal with lots of countries
that aren't like we are
if we only dealt with countries that
were exactly like we are we wouldn't
have many people to deal with
very good
what can be done to keep iran from
becoming a nuclear power
is it up to israel
well my guess is probably
you don't see the u.n the quote
international community which of course
isn't a community at all
it's it's a bunch of countries and and
uh but
the they're so divided on this issue
and you're not going to get the un to
take the kinds of steps that would
would uh create an a circumstance
inside of iran that they would find it
disadvantageous
to have nuclear weapons i'm out of date
by at least four years and but but my
recollection is
the last time i looked i was hoping at
one point that the iranian people
would oppose the ayatollahs
and that they didn't wouldn't want to be
separate from the rest of the world and
that they would see that nuclear weapons
programs of the
iranian government were causing the
iranian people to be somewhat separated
from the rest of the world
i mean there's a big country it's a
proud country
turns out the last data i saw suggested
that the iranian people
didn't want to not be disconnected from
the rest of the world
but they they were not opposed to a
nuclear program
so that is it turned out that that might
not be
the wedge that could separate the
iranian people from the
uh their leadership the ayatollahs i
don't know if that's still
true but but i remember that having been
true four five six years ago
and uh but but it it
it doesn't make sense to me that that
forever the ayatollahs are going to be
in charge of that country i mean i think
those people at some point conceivably
could overthrow the uh the government
and we we missed an opportunity to help
them
and and provide encouragement um
there may be other opportunities in the
future certainly this administration
isn't going to do anything with respect
to the
iranian nuclear capability
the the israelis
in the past of course took out the iraqi
nuclear
capability and when they went in
some many years ago now more recently
they
dealt with syrian nuclear capabilities
and they they have some capabilities to
do these things but it's complicated
it's not easy
and one has to believe the iranians are
arranging themselves in a way that it'll
be
difficult so the best one could hope for
would be to delay their program
but they uh or you know who knows what's
gonna happen there's a split right now
possibly between some of the uh leaders
the president
and and some of the ayatollahs over
different issues
and there may be more things that can be
done
and we just have to hope but but it's
sitting there hoping
that the un will step up and and uh
show some um leadership on it i think is
is uh not going to happen i just don't
see them doing that
our alliance with israel is it still
important and what do you think its
prospects are
it's it's very important it's critically
important to israel
and i think it's important to us this is
a country that's a democracy
it is uh it's been a friend and and
we've had a close relationship
not a formal alliance as such like we do
at nato or a treaty
such as we have with south korea or
japan but it has been a country that
we've cooperated with closely
it's a country that is in a hostile part
of the world
hostile to them uh fortunately
the arrangements that sadat initiated
mubarak followed up on
for provided a long period of stability
in the region
and that's at risk right now we don't
know where the egyptian
situation is going to evolve the um
the different forces tugging and pulling
in there
create a big question mark as to as to
who will prevail and
and we know that that extremists tend to
be better organized and
and more vicious and more determined
than
than disparate groups that have
different opinions and aren't as well
organized
so there's a risk it seems to me that
egypt could end up with a
a government that might not be willing
to continue
its relationship with israel that they
had and and that puts israel in a very
tough spot uh but but we um
for myself i think it's important that
we recognize the uh
uh the relationship and that we
recognize the difficulty of their
situation
and uh and be a friend a strong friend
and the deterrent effect of that is
substantial
and to the extent the deterrent effect
is weakened we're
we're asking for trouble and uh
this administration's relationship with
israel i think has been
imperfect at best and and dangerous
in some respects the rudeness of it
somebody wants to know is it possible to
build a democracy in a muslim country
time will tell um well time will tell i
mean
i guess the the closest thing you've got
is what's going on in
uh in afghanistan and iraq
and and that's imperfect uh
but they are finding their way and the
fact that it's imperfect uh so were we
imperfect in various stages of our
development
um and and uh i i don't know the answer
i know that there are notable
differences
in iraq from our country and notable
differences in afghanistan from both
iraq and our country
and they're going to have to find their
way we can give them the opportunity but
we can't do it for them
and we can give them a chance to make it
and
and hope they do i don't know maybe it's
a bad way to think of it but
you know if you've got a youngster and
you're teaching them to ride a bike you
put your hand on the steering wheel
i'm a correction on the seat on a
bicycle and you run down the street with
them
and holding on and then pretty soon you
go to three fingers
and then you go to two fingers and then
you go to one finger
and they might fall and skim their knees
but if you don't let go you're going to
end up with a 40 year old that can't
ride a bike and
it it's
you you can't do it for them and if
the american people have a tendency to
want to do it
if there's a ditch to be done by golly
we want to dig the ditch and we can dig
a darn good ditch
but if there's 15 million ditches to be
dug you darn well better teach other
people how to
dig a ditch and not expect that it'll be
exactly the way we would have done it
and it because it won't be
don't you wonder about the the questions
that he
rejects he goes through there and he
yeah he smiles and he takes the one he
likes and chucks the other one
yeah if you do wonder keep wondering
one of the worst mistakes we made in
iraq
i suppose uh not anticipating the
insurgency
which kind of evolved in a in a way a
hundred
saddam was saying let a hundred thousand
prisoners out of the camps
his prisons and and the
young military people that were let go
out of the army didn't get paid for a
period of
many weeks saddam hussein called for
jihad and they started streaming in over
the border
the um party of return was the what the
sunnis
decided and uh and then al qaeda
migrated in there and started working
with the sunnis and the sunnis were
made a big mistake to not participate in
the government at the outset and they
played with al qaeda until al qaeda
started raping their women and stealing
their businesses
and then they decided they didn't like
that and that led to the awakening
but a combination of those things
conspired to create an
insurgency of some intensity that had
not been
predicted or anticipated and uh and it
kept evolving
in a way that was different
you know the the the way it
eventually was dealt with was a
combination of things that came together
in in a very helpful way number one the
sunnis got tired of al qaeda uh doing
what they were doing and
and uh migrated towards the
support of the maliki government sadder
it was a problem uh he went quiet
for some reason he may have gone to iran
but he went quiet
uh third the iraqi military and security
forces were developed into the hundreds
of thousands by then and
and equipped and were petraeus was in we
put petraeus in charge of it
and he uh and and then his successor
general dempsey uh got the iraqi forces
up to a level that they could really
make a difference in participating with
our forces
and then you know george w bush
by being bold and and announcing the
surge
the other thing was the maliki
government matured somewhat and actually
got tough enough and went down south and
did some damage
damage in a good sense and then
president bush god bless them
galvanized support in the united states
they
senator reid had already said the war is
lost it's over
and uh he galvanized support in the
united states with the surge and
his decision galvanized support in in
iraq because
people were starting to think well
they're going to pull out the congress
is going to jerk the money away and
and god bless him for it he deserves a
lot of credit in my view
i'll ask one more so i i understand that
uh secretary has to drive down to
houston tonight so i'm going to cancel
flights
yeah can't get in and out of this place
so i'm going to ask you one more
question that i'm going to give you a
chance to say whatever you want to say
and what is your opinion of
you can see why i saved this one
president obama's leadership in the war
on terror
oh my
[Applause]
well let me say this about that
he campaigned first of all the
structures that president bush's
administration put in place
um i am absolutely convinced
have helped to protect the american
people for close to a decade
the obama people campaigned against most
of them
against the patriot act against
indefinite detention against guantanamo
bay
against renditions against enhanced
interrogation techniques waterboarding
and he then got into office and he has
reversed himself
on most of them not completely
reversed himself but he is kept in place
many of those structures that have in my
view
helped to protect our country he is
still hoping he can close guantanamo of
course everyone hopes you could close
guantanamo
but uh you know if you're going to tear
down what is you darn well
better have something better to put in
its place and no one's thought of what's
better
i think that that he is a been reluctant
to accept reality although
in many instances now he has accepted
reality
um he the the
concept of leading from behind
as i think someone in his administration
suggested
is is worrisome uh i don't know who you
want in front
you know is it sudan or
some other country that you can think of
that you'd prefer to provide the
guidance
i was asked one time why president
obama didn't go to congress and ask for
uh
authority to go into libya and i said he
didn't know what to ask for
he hadn't decided he instead of
recognizing that the
the mission ought to determine the
coalition uh where you decide what you
want to do and then you get countries
that want to do that
he decided he would go to nato and the
u.n and get a coalition
and then they would decide what they
were going to do what their role was
in libya and that is worrisome because
it you're not going to get countries
that are going to stay under the
umbrella
if you haven't in the first instance
decided what it is
you were going to do and uh so i i
i am personally one that
that believes that we have a great
country
that it is not an accident that people
are lined up all across the globe
wanting to come here
and he seems not to feel that way
and i think that's unfortunate and i i
hope that he'll
begin to better understand what an
amazing country this
is and the fact that that it
[Applause]
but i i i think that
the leadership he's providing is
better than he started out but it still
has a good ways to go
thank you
larry asked me if there's anything else
the only thing i would say is that i
really do
thank all of you for supporting
hillsdale
it's a special place and what you're
doing is the right thing
it's a good thing and uh
the leadership's questionable but
but it's tough to get good help
he's doing a great job thank you
you